equations
let's think back a little bit um we
looked at
the difference between
words
right
and algebra
we saw that
this algebra idea we could use
to talk about numbers even when we
didn't know what they were actually
equal to okay which is really really
cool we could take
words a sentence like say a number times
itself or a number plus three or
something like that and we could convert
it into algebra do you remember that
yeah good
now we also looked and we saw
that when you put together a whole bunch
of words
we call that a sentence
when you put a whole bunch of words
together
you get a sentence right now you're very
careful
we talked about this before
you put a bunch of algebra and numbers
together right there's a special word
and it wasn't this one that also started
with a here expression an expression
well done
now this is really important
remember i said
um because a lot of people said oh you
know when you put a bunch of algebra
numbers together you get an equation
well sometimes you do i'll talk about
what that is in a second but sometimes
you don't right what is the difference
between the expression
and an equation yes i have
an expression
okay good so this one doesn't have an
equal sign whereas this one does and the
way you can tell is because the word
equation it has it almost has the word
equal
in it right okay so here's the idea
right and this is what you want to have
there
you put words together you get a
sentence
when you put algebra and numbers
together you get an expression but but
if the algebra
and numbers
together
if the sentence that we put together
includes something like
all of this stuff this algebra numbers
is equal to or is the same as or
equivalent to or this other algebra
numbers that's what makes an equation so
together with
what i'm going to call that is a
statement
of
equality
in other words
i'm saying this thing and this thing
they're equal okay and that's why we use
an equal slope right so algebraic
numbers together with a statement of
equality
gives
an equation so let me give you
an example okay really really simple
okay yeah what do you mean by equality
okay let me show you let me show you so
here you go
k plus three
that there that's algebra
and number
right that's an expression yeah
but the second i say look i want to make
a standard equality i want to say this
is equal to something else maybe i say
that's equal to fine aha
now i have with my color
now i have an equation
okay so this whole thing right
that's an equation
it has it makes a statement about two
things and their equality k plus three
and five they have this equivalent they
are equal to each other okay